and we are back welcome to the heavy
spoiler show i'm your host paul
aka the fly guy who's pretty armless
outside of his bad puns in this video
we're breaking down episode one of
falcon in the winter soldier
taking place roughly six months after
the events of avengers endgame
we follow sam and bucky as they adjust
to their life after the blip
it's a better pilot than the dude
hijacking the plane and it makes for an
awesome opening that's gonna have myself
and area the marvel maniac grip for the
next six
weeks throughout this video we're going
to be breaking down the story
easter eggs things you missed and how
the characters compare to the comics to
give our fan theories on why
everyone is mephisto now we start off
with sam ironing his shirt
but what we discover is an event at the
smithsonian which involves him handing
his shield over to the captain america
exhibit
you may remember that this first
appeared in captain america the winter
soldier
and both stephen bucky ventured out to
it during the film
sam places the shield back into the
brown bag that steve gave him
metaphorically symbolizing how he has
returned it to the place that it came
from
over the top of the scene we hear the
dialogue from endgame in which steve
asked sam how it felt with the shield
he replied with like it's someone else's
and this line is clearly a driving force
for the character's actions
as he very much feels like he can't live
up to the mantle
now though we only get brief glimpses of
his room this does help to paint out his
mind state
often in tv shows and films the way
people's houses are kept
can signal what's going on with them
mentally sam's room is a bit
messy which completely juxtaposes the
appearance that he's trying to give off
with the suit
this could showcase that he's trying to
present to the world that everything's
a-okay
when as we learn throughout the episode
he's struggling with a lot of issues
bit of a reach here however we can
compare this room to what the avengers
lived in at the hq
and this feels a lot more like sam is on
tough times
which is confirmed later on with the
banker and he's a right bloody banker
now the avengers including sam were
instrumental in saving the universe
and though the thank yous that they
receive are great it's clear that the
character isn't being showered with
riches
so he still struggles with keeping a
roof over his head now this is likely
why he had to re-enlist in the air force
and in the winter soldier we learned
that he was part of a power rescue unit
however after his wingman pun intended
died
he turned to helping veterans with ptsd
sam has returned to active duty and we
watch as he tackles a group known as the
laf who have hijacked a plane
they're led by batroc the lieber who you
will probably remember from the winter
soldier
he's gone from hijacking boats to
hijacking planes
and it's an awesome action scene to kick
start the series with
the character appears in purple and
yellow similar to how he did in the
winter soldier
and these are the colours that he
typically tends to don
now batrock is a french native who
joined the foreign legion where he was
trained in combat before he became an
intelligence officer in the french
secret service
credited with 36 kill missions he was an
amazing asset to the french government
but when he realized his skills could be
used for profit
the character became a mercenary wanted
by the fbi
sas and interpol he gained a big
reputation
which is when he caught the eyes of nick
fury or rather just the eye now fury
paid the character to hijack a vessel at
the start of the winter soldier
and using this as cover natasha was able
to sneak in
and carry out a classified mission to
uncover secrets about project insight
he's an expert in hand-to-hand combat
and though he's had his butt handed to
him by both cap and his sidekick
i definitely think that he will be back
in the series now another reach here but
the officer tells sam that the op has to
be subtle and sam then falls backwards
out the plane in a christ-like pose
this kind of imagery is present in a lot
of superhero films
and we're at a point now where even zack
snyder is meaning on himself for all his
callbacks to christ
i don't know if they're making fun of
this motif here but it is quite strange
how they have this play out immediately
after saying how things should be kept
soul
now it's during this scene that we
introduced the first lieutenant taurus
who you may recognize as a big player in
the graphic novel run
sam wilson captain america in the work
taurus was captured by a group known as
the serpent
society and he was experimented on made
into a half
man half falcon hybrid the character
ended up becoming somewhat of a sidekick
to sam
throughout most of the run the book was
kick-started with an elderly captain
america giving the shield to sam
and he had to deal with how unpopular
this was whilst also making his own way
during 84 us agent the flag smasher and
teamed up with bucky so it does seem to
be a basis for this adaptation
i think they will probably take some
elements of that and
ground it a lot more with characters
like taurus potentially becoming the new
falcon
when sam eventually becomes captain
america which yeah
probably gonna be how the show ends we
see this grounded aesthetic applied to a
lot of aspects in the mcu
such as sam and the bird red wing whom
can telepathically communicate with one
another in the source material
as always in this continuity sam
controls the machine through an ear link
up
but it is important to see how these
things are set up in the comics and how
they are carried across
now red wing is also important because
you know who else has a red wing
mephisto
[Music]
i'm telling you gonna do one of those a
video alright so keep an eye out for
them now we do learn that red wing has
been
outfitted with the latest stark
technology and actually see some of iron
man's weapons being used on the bird
including a laser
which can cut through the doors on the
plane this laser also appeared in
infinity war
as a way for stock to cut a hole in
ebony moore's ship it's an incredible
action scene in which we see sam using
the wings like a shield
and this is a very important
characteristic for captain america to
have
in the book that the series is based on
they even have a whole bit about how
cap chose his symbol to be a shield
rather than a gun
as he wanted to be seen as a defender
instead of a conqueror
though subtle it does show that sam has
what it takes to be cap
even though he may not believe it
himself after taking to the skies we
watch as sam has an aerial dogfight with
some helicopters
as he tries to retrieve the contact from
batroc's men
in our trailer breakdown for the show we
did say that these jumpsuits looked very
similar to ones used by hydra
but after watching the episode i'm not
sure whether they're involved or not
yep one division has officially killed
my need to do fan theories
they are still out there as we last saw
them taking crosses pin particles and
ant-man
but it's likely that the imagery just
looks similar rather than them being
linked to the events
sam saves the contact before they hit
the libyan border
and we join him in torres in tunisia
where the pair discuss the villains of
the peace
that is the flag smashes these guys
are sort of a flash mob that's similar
to the laf
are taking advantage of all the chaos
caused by the blip
now in the comics this wasn't a group
and instead it was a single man who went
under the moniker
flag smasher believed that nationalism
was a real problem in the world
and nussie had a vendetta against
captain america who was of course the
symbol of an entire country
in sam wilson captain america we
actually come across an lmd version of
the character at one point
and he goes off on a monologue about how
all the borders should be open across
the world
as this will truly provide people with
freedom instead of making them have to
bend to the will of the government
as mentioned he was adverse to
nationalism because
he believed that it always led to
fascism and fascism always led to war
thus in his mind by stopping humanity
from going down this path
he was saving several lives they sort of
play lip service to the bit about
borders with taurus explaining the
motives of the group
but one of the major things that isn't
in the comics that he brings up
is that they think life was better in
the blip as sam states
if something gets good for one group it
usually gets worse for another
and it sort of got me thinking about the
economy in the blip itself
say you were a factory worker at amazon
if the board members in middle
management all got dusted
then chances are you'd get promoted to
something quite high up
you'd get more money and could have a
better standard of living
which could be the sort of thing that
taurus is referring to
now because the snap was also just 50
percent of the planet
and not 50 percent of certain areas
there may have been some countries that
lost a lot of their population
whereas others didn't and the talk of
borders could have meant that they
opened up a lot more
so people had free travel we've never
really seen the inner workings of what
happened during the blip
but something that's interesting with
the flag smashes that we see
is that they have super human abilities
this could either be because they're
they're super soldiers themselves
mutants or even scrolls yeah we're back
on the fan theory train now
now personally i'm leaning more in with
the first theory as that's obviously
tied to captain america
but let me know below exactly what you
think now in one division we watched as
hayward tried to resurrect the vision
in order to provide the planet with a
defense system and it is possible that
the flag smashers were experimented on
for this very reason
flag smasher in the comics on the whole
just tended to be a normal guy with a
skill set better than liam neeson's
but looks like they've changed a lot of
stuff here now an interesting aspect is
that captain america has disappeared
a lot of people myself included believe
that the show would start with sam and
bucky faking his death
so that he could lie in peace but it is
known that the character is alive and
well
one of the fan theories is that he's
hidden away on the moon
but as we all know he's actually the
president of the united states
now moon bases have appeared in the
comics there's even one that the
watchers
used to spy on earth from it's also tied
in heavily with the inhumans
but whether they appear or not what
we're just gonna have to see however
the idea of him being hidden away in
space could be a node of the avengers
game in which he was placed on an
orbiting satellite around the planet
what thing happened though ties back to
the way that the russo brothers
described the ending of endgame
and though this contradicts what the
writers have put out russo said that
when cap went back in time to have a
life with peggy
he actually created a branch timeline
where the pair lived together
at the end of the movie he then
journeyed back to the main one
and handed sam the shield if that's the
case then the guy probably just jumped
back to his one
and that's why there's no trace of him
in this show
now sam returns the shield to the
smithsonian which the government thanked
him for
and we also get rody stopping by too i
know the phrase luke skywalker level
cameo
has been banded about a lot recently but
yeah even though it wasn't that level
it was nice to see him pop up here as
he's one of my favorite characters in
the mcu
now there is an ulterior motive going on
here and we learn at the end of the
episode that the government wanted the
shield so that they could appoint their
own captain america
namely john walker played by wyatt
russell this cosplay cap in the comics
is a character known as us
agent who from time to time has walked
the line between being a hero and
villain
i'll talk about this more later on but
because of the way that the government
official says to sam it was the right
thing to do
i kind of feel like they might have put
pressure on him to hand over the shield
you don't just make a captain america
overnight and he was likely put through
testing phases with the other applicants
so i feel like this has been in the
making for a long time
sam clearly regrets his decision
realizing he gave up the mantle
and we also get a great scene in the
smithsonian where he and rody discuss
the shield and what it means
there's a great bit of symbolism here
where we see a poster of steve with
i want you written on the top of it and
sam stands directly in front of it
because of the way that it's lined up
steve is pointing to sam
saying he wants him to become captain
america but sam just doesn't feel like
he's a worthy replacement
there is further symbolism when sam
stands in front of the shield
but he's slightly off-center showing
that he doesn't quite align with it yet
this iconography was too used and into
the spider-verse
with miles not having his face line up
with the mask before it did when he was
ready
cut to one of the winter soldier's
missions years ago and we see as he
takes out a vip
and all of his security team though this
is a flashback
it does feel like a nod to the comic
book run as in that the first time that
we see bucky
he's doing something similar like that
moment in the book we
don't quite know the time period that
this scene takes place in
and it feels like it's put there to make
us think that bucky might have turned to
the dark side
hail snyder however whereas in that
it was shown to just be be totally
innocent he was just doing a mission
here it's a flashback because the winter
soldier needed to remain a myth
he also made us someone who's a witness
to the mission and we later learned that
this is the son of a man that bucky has
been trying to make amends with
in fact the entire arc he goes on in
this episode seems to be him
trying to right the wrongs of the past
we also join him in therapy with a
character
that we know from the trailers will be
returning buggy has trouble adjusting
because of his life as the winter
soldier
and in real world terms this phrase
actually means someone who just goes
from war to war
which because of his hibernation he
ended up doing
bucky journeyed to a senator that was a
hydra pawn and someone that continued to
abuse her power
even after they fell bucky beat up one
of her hired assassins
and then stated that he changed before
handing over info to the authorities
so that they could arrest her now this
scene in the way that we see a man and
woman in a car
felt very similar in serb in the way
that it was shot to the murder of the
stalks
whereas in that he killed howard before
moving on to maria
here he just hits the guy in the face
and leans in the window to tell the
senator
that he's changed another interesting
aspect that we learn in this scene is
that bucky is truly alone
he hasn't text anyone has the social
life of a youtuber
and i think this series will set him up
with a relationship and that he will
actually start dating people
we then jump to his home in brooklyn
which of course he and steve lived in
his kids
he breaks up another fight involving a
trash can in an alley
and also says that he hasn't danced
since 1943
which of course is something that was
murdered in steve now the father's story
about his son
is heartbreaking because he says he will
never know what happened to his son
bucky doesn't tell him in this episode
but i think a big moment will come in
the season when he finally does
jump to louisiana to see sam going home
anthony mackie is actually from here so
this is also a cool little time to him
we learned that his parents are called
paul which is a great name and darlene
and also meet his sister and his nephews
his nephews were teased in a recent xbox
ad
i think i don't know i never have time
to play games anymore
and we learn that their parents
shrimping business is hanging on by a
thread
that's only being kept afloat by his
sister sarah
bucky chats up a lovely lady and she
says that he sounds like her dad
probably because the lad is 106 love he
also says he wears a glove because of
poor circulation
but it's more like no circulation hey
having that
great joke now the pair play battleships
and a drinking game
which involves telling the truth bucky
pretty much
paints out that he has no family and we
see the guilt get
far too much for him which makes him
almost confess the murder
however he doesn't and he just pays for
the lunch but we see that nakajima is
number one on the list
showing how highly he views writing this
wrong in switzerland
we see the attack by the flag smashers
in which they steal some unknown objects
at the location people are handed out
masks and then told to ren
which is run in swiss see whilst new
rock stars yeah they're translating
latin we're over here translating ren
to run now all the people running about
and causing chaos
that allows flag samasha to escape and
the so-called leader of them
easily beats up torres before making off
into the night
at the bank though falcon is seen as a
hero it doesn't mean much when it comes
to money
and his loan request is rejected because
he has no credit history due to the snap
you think the bank would take that into
account but the character leaves without
getting anything other than a selfie
also the license plate as usual could
have significance to them
the one we see in this scene says 184
which is an issue of captain america and
the falcon
in which the red skull returns and holds
america hostage
there's also a bit where the names of
the producers appear on screen for the
names of the vanished
and this includes victoria alonso who's
headed up many marvel projects
sam refusing to sell their parents
legacy returns to the boat to try and
start it
but it doesn't work also we see a little
bird and a globe on the dash
and a birdie striker because he's called
falcon
best easter eggs on the net folks doris
then sends him a video message of the
flag smashes
and we get the crushing news
announcement that there's a new captain
america
which ends the episode now who exactly
is this
well as mentioned earlier this is john
walker
the new captain america we're going to
be breaking him down in just a bit but
if you're enjoying the video so far then
i'd massively appreciate the thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe and click
the bell to never miss one of our weekly
breakdowns on the show
i also want to thank all of you for your
support on one division as it helped me
to get early access to this episode
and it's meant i can take more time so i
appreciate each and every one of you
now us agent was first introduced in the
comics as the super villain super
patriot
walker was accounted to captain america
and he was set up as a way to embody the
patriotism in opposite to the hero
whereas cap showed off the good aspects
of american patriotism
walker showed off the bad bits and this
put the pair at odds with one another he
did kind of go back and forth as a hero
and villain over the years
and currently he stands as someone who's
mainly a good guy
now at one point when steve quit his cap
he stepped into his shoes
but wasn't really that well received so
if if you want a good analogy then think
of asriel and batman nightfall and you
sort of get the idea
in having him take over the role it
helped to better define what
captain america truly meant by showing
what it shouldn't mean
and this will likely be carried across
to the series feel like walker will
initially appear in a positive light and
end up attending parades and so on
but he will have a lot more of a
sinister side to him and will eventually
go toe-to-toe with sam
in the comics namely sam wilson captain
america
he's actually hired by captain america
to fight sam
and the pair face off against one
another in a big action scene
now cap did this because look it was a
weird time when when him saying things
like hail hydra that was all about
you know this stuff and yeah it was a
weird one point is though
that this was sanctioned by a government
figurehead
an agent actually refused to fight sam
until cap stepped in and told him what
to do
i think at some point walker might be
reluctant to take on sam
but that the government may push him
into doing it because he makes them look
bad
either way though i'm very excited for
the future and on the whole i
absolutely love the first episode having
the snyder cut in this release back to
back has made this for an amazing week
and both are great comic book entries
that you definitely should check out
whereas i was a bit unsure on one
division in the first two episodes
here i'm completely on board the acting
is superb
the production quality is amazing and
this really feels like a film
that not only has amazing moments of
action but also
necessary human drama that you should be
getting from these conflicted characters
i really didn't think there would be
many fan theories that we could make
with this show but my mind's already
racing over what could happen next
where steve is and what's going on with
the flag smashes
though zemo is absent for now going
forward he will obviously be a big
player as will sharon carter
i think it's also a testament to how
good this episode is that sam and bucky
never actually meet
and we're still just as hyped to see
them on screen
i think the latter will probably go to
the former asking for help which will
also be a great moment
and this will sort of set up the flag
smasher showdown as well as the zemo
arc overall this is a brilliant first
entry
and we now know from the director that
the series will be setting up three more
mcu stories
i'm guessing that there are armor wars
secret invasion
and potentially ms marvel but we will of
course have to see
a big plotline involving a virus was
apparently reworked in the wake of the
pandemic
so who knows that may even be terrigen
missed and we could be getting the
inhumans at some point
i don't know yeah i'm gonna stop with
these fan theories but what an
absolutely incredible way to bring us
back to the mcu with a bang
even though it's just been one empty
week since one division
that the wait yeah it felt so long and
i'm glad that we have some more amazing
content like this to tie us over until
may
which hopefully is when black widow
releases fingers crossed yeah
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the episode so make sure you
comment below and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
during the 31st of march in which we're
giving away three copies of a marvel 4k
box set of your choice all you have to
do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our ending
explained breakdown of the snyder cut
in which we talk about not only what
those final scenes mean
but also what's meant to be happening in
justice league two and three
if they ever get made thank you for
sitting through the video
i've been paul i hope you have a great
weekend and i'll see you next friday
take care peace